the Leicester University now have my job
earning a good income in 2007 had
financial crisis I can't invest in
property that would have been the best
time 2020 human had the pandemic I was
more prepared and now's the best time to
kind of go out and take advantage you've
got eight rent to rent how much does an
average rent to a bank would you say
typically in London bringing is under
100K worth of fees damn bro the best way
to sell is not actually selling selling
but through telling stories buying a
house in the UK is ridiculously long I'm
changing that what is best being around
people within the academy it kind of
pushes you even further how can you
expect people to invest in you when you
don't even invest in you the thing is
landlords generally want two things they
want their rent to be paid on time and
they want the property to pick up to
good condition I'm offering a service
here I'm often value to you it's a
no-brainer like why would you not do a
rent to rent
well firstly thanks for coming to my
house and congratulations on your huge
success you've done uh real estate in
many different dimensions rent to rent
buy to let estate agency what's your
favorite part to property and real
estate I think my bread and butter was
ready to rent yeah that's how kind of
got started and for me what has kind of
been my core of the business so
obviously right now I do quite a few
things in property so I like to call
them my pillars and in the center of
that is is rent to rent so property
management and then I do like what I've
recently kind of got into when I went
full time in property which is selling
real estate especially kind of the
luxury end of selling real estate so for
me that's that's exciting how much
property have you sold them over the
last year or so so I got started selling
real estate last year so in my first
year I sold four houses uh so a Circa
five million pound worth of kind of
sales yeah bringing under 100K worth of
fees 100k
and that's just that's just not even the
main pillar yeah it's not a main pillar
it's 100K worth of feed obviously it was
all in my pocket obviously when I first
kind of got started with one of the
companies that are kind of disrupting
the market which is tyrannash real
estate yeah the amazing things in terms
of changing the way how Estates is done
so obviously at the moment in the UK you
got the big corporate entities like
foxtons
Dexter's so we've looked to like places
like America for example and you've got
people like Ryan Serhant or Josh Altman
or you go to Australia tompanos these
amazing people that have like
accountability and helping their clients
get get great results and I think that
was kind of needed in the UK so I think
what you all see going forward in the
next few years to come is a lot more
personal agents like myself like
clarinet or all the hundreds that will
be coming very forward helping their
clients get amazing results because you
watch the movies or the documentaries
where they're selling houses in America
America and they're getting like paid
like a million pounds to sell a house
and stuff like that and it's just crazy
it doesn't really happen here in the UK
so much it doesn't not at all and
another thing is as well the higher end
market like you're talking about selling
five houses and making 100 Grand in fees
like if you're selling a small house and
a big house the effort's the same so
we've got some houses coming up they're
up north uh in Blackpool landlord
sending his portfolio
um it's worth about four million but it
has about 40 houses yeah well you can
sell four houses and get the same fees
or one hour one house exactly yeah
definitely if you've got to do something
makes you work smarter do you know what
I mean yeah so rent to rents are kind of
the pillar of of your of your business
how many rental events do you have at
the moment so we've got eight rent to
rent in the business five of which are
hmos and then since leaving the eviction
we went on to take free essays so right
now it's kind of a mixture of having
hmos nsas for me I think it's always
good to have a hybrid approach in terms
of whatever you're doing so that if and
if it was to happen in in the market
like another pandemic or whatever like
that is you can easily switch between
nightly stays or on monthly stays so
when you've got rental rents you've got
a service accommodation which is short
stay let's you've got your own estate
agency where you're selling High
high-end properties how do you focus
when you've got so much different things
and different so many different
strategies going on I mean is that a
good thing or do you find yourself
scattered what do you think so I think
definitely you've got to have a lot of
structure in terms of what it is that
you're doing when you are kind of doing
multiple things and for me especially
kind of doing this kind of that
full-time is has helped me to kind of
structure what it is I'm doing and focus
in different parts of the business and
then also delegating as well which is
very very important something which I've
had transferable skills so I used to be
a project manager and that was my bread
and butter so that has enabled me how to
kind of delegate what it is that I need
to kind of get done across across that
business what was your previous
occupancy what we did in exactly so I
was a project manager for the largest
airplane manufacturer in the world which
is a Boeing so I was handling a lot of
their I.T implementation projects so
they are predominantly an American
company so my role was to kind of help
them transfer over their software
Solutions into the International Space
and how did you go from that to getting
into property what happened well I mean
I've always had a passion for for
property from a very very young age I
think my family's kind of always kind of
been around property my granddad when he
kind of first came over to the UK so he
came over from Jamaica during the kind
of the wind Rush area
um and he actually lived in a HMO but it
probably wasn't called a HMO back then
so him and my grandma lived in a house
they had a room and obviously rented out
their rooms in the house yeah so one of
the things he always said there was one
invest in property and two uh get get a
trade learn a trade and so I've always
kind of been around kind of property
environment my mum's a was a landlord
kind of growing up and seeing her invest
in property and kind of being a landlord
and then went to University started
business and marketing at University and
you know what I've always been had an
entrepreneurial background entrepreneur
spirit I mean sorry it's always wanted
to kind of Be My Own Boss and kind of
invest in property watching things like
homes under the hammer yeah that was
that was my thing I let them inspire me
homeser than the hammer I had a good job
out of University I was self-employed
driving instructor and indecent money at
the time great I'm going to save up a
pot of cash I'm going to invest into
property so Leicester University now
have my job earning a good income in
2007 he had financial crisis and I
thought damn I can't invest in property
now everyone's let's say the Market's
crashing so you don't know what you
don't know it's at that time I wasn't
very uneducated that would have been the
best time yeah to take advantage of of
that situation so I ended up kind of
doing driving instruction for a number
of years then kind of wanted to change
career and they went to kind of the
corporate world so retrained an I.T
started out as an intern then Rose
myself up through the company hard work
grind and then became a project manager
but in the back of my mind there was
always that kind of burning desire to
kind of get back into property so it
wasn't until 2019 summer on YouTube rent
to rent seeing yourself there talking
about this amazing thing that you can
kind of do in property where you can
control property without actually kind
of owning this this is amazing great
2020 we had a situation we had the
pandemic but for me I now was in a
better situation because I knew I was
more prepared and now's the best time to
kind of go out and take advantage of
offering landlords a service that is
happening in the world we can give you
guaranteed rent I think there's so many
people that are in normal jobs that have
a desire to get into property to be
their own boss yeah how long did it take
you from when you just saw the YouTube
videos you know you joined the academy
around what when did you join the
academy and come to stop coming to the
trainings when was that so it was
December December December 2020 2020. so
back in the 2020 how long did it take
you from really deciding right I'm going
to go at it we're in lockdown pandemic
joining the academy before getting to
the point whereby you were financially
independent and you could leave your job
so yeah so the beginning of 20 and 20.
um obviously when we had kind of
pandemic it's obviously through all the
videos and obviously kind of started off
kind of doing it stuff on my own and
reaching out to yourself and other
mentors to kind of help me kind of get
this first rent to rent and it was kind
of really the end of 2020 you know what
I need to really kind of scale and kind
of grow this and obviously being around
like people within the academy it kind
of puts you even further to come and be
get more and do more rather than having
that kind of limiting belief yeah when
did you go full-time in property so
full-time property was last year 2021
2020 on my birthday oh congratulations
so with your and with your hmos and you
make Dimension stuff yeah they're in
London yeah how are you finding the
market with getting landlords to agree
to give you their properties in London
because one of the things that I'm
hearing a lot is that London's a tough
Market London's tough I mean landlords
are absolutely greedy at the moment yeah
obviously the rents are kind of going up
at the moment obviously what's kind of
going on with the cost of living and
just trying to kind of get landlords
agree a decent rent is is hard at the
same time but sometimes you've got to
find a landlord who needs a problem
solving whether he has a house for
example it needs work doing to it so
recently we took on property with the
land or did that many money but his
property wasn't a terrible state so we
offered him a service that offered him a
solution so it's all about trying to
find a win-win so to speak for for the
landlord uh obviously you have other
factors that are inflating the market
especially in London a lot of people
kind of doing supported living
which is kind of giving the landlords
the kind of impression oh I can get five
grand for my three bedroom house where
out up somewhere else up you can get
something different how are you finding
landlords and how are you pitching them
on doing a rental rent so you have
landlords I think it's about having a
good conversation understanding what are
the pain points because the end of the
day they were landlord they got into it
to probably kind of do it themselves so
the best way to try and get your good
landlords is kind of direct rather than
obviously going through an estate agent
have a conversation try to listen and
understand what their pain points are
whether it's managing the tenants
they're not paying the rent having to do
all the maintenance issues and often say
what I can take away that burden from
you I can give you the guaranteed rent
they're looking for the Peace of Mind
especially for example now with the
mortgage rates kind of going up they
might not make as much money is looking
at creative strategies like service
accommodation or hmos that they maybe
even come in on a profit share for
example okay have you got that with your
rent to rent I haven't got a property at
the moment but it's something that I
will be kind of doing
forward right as it will help me scale a
lot quicker in terms of taking on I mean
you've got a pretty you've got eight
rent Dimensions you've got three more
going through at the moment you're
making very good money how much just
does an average rent to web mate would
you say typically in London so typically
in London you're looking back for HMO is
about 800 pounds
so if you've got two or three of those
that's going to replace your salary yeah
but I'm just trying to work out like you
say speak to your landlords direct find
their pain points how do you find
landlords direct where's the where do
you go the best place for me to kind of
go is Gumtree Facebook open rent so
where landlords are advertising their
properties they're trying to do it to
themselves they're trying to get out of
paying a state agency the amount of work
with an estate agent they're not happy
with their service and they're kind of
getting they're feeling they're very
lazy and they want to kind of I can do
it myself also networking So speaking to
landlords at networking events so going
to like the nrla and they put on
Thousand events or the property investor
show and speaking to landlords you want
to circulate with them do you think
sometimes rent to rent has a little bit
of almost like a bad name like landlords
are a bit like oh yeah whereas actually
it's like well sorry it's a brilliant
service we're given a guaranteed rent
with a nice company contract on a
long-term leagues what where does the
stigma come from for me it's a
no-brainer like why would you not do a
rent to rent because you're not trying
to get a property that's a thousand
pounds a month and try and knock them
down to 600. you're generally paying the
going rate but then just increasing the
value by running it on short stay let's
if it's inset obviously if it's in
greater London there's rules and there's
laws you may not be able to do that you
may have to do it as a HMO but where do
you think the stigma comes from I think
the stigma comes from a lot of people
doing it incorrectly yeah especially in
the in the beginning when rent to rent
was a buzzword they learned lots and
lots of money doing it you don't own
property you just control it yeah so a
lot of people are uneducated doing it so
a lot of the time when you're calling in
landlords or stage and say no sorry
don't do company let's we're actually
listening and understanding value in it
the beauty about rent to rent is you're
offering a service and that's what you
as a rent to renter have to kind of go
into that conversation and believe in
I'm offering a service here I'm often
value to you in terms of what it is that
you're providing what do you say when a
landlord says because I know what I say
you know what you say when a landlord
says we don't do company that's no we
don't do commit do you go on a problem
or do you talk around what would you say
I have to say okay I understand many
people language that I speak to
initially say they don't do compliments
can I understand what's your particular
reason because my landlord I spoke to
was he didn't want to do complex because
he felt that property might have been
devalued and we had a conversation about
it and said uh explaining our model but
let me understand Mr Lantern what's your
reason why so I've got to find them the
reason why to kind of get them to open
up yeah oh yeah I had a bad experience
had to accomplished they didn't pay the
rent okay I understand obviously it'll
be that terrible if someone didn't pay
the rent and I understand how you must
feel you didn't get to pay your mortgage
on time so get their pain points you've
got to make them feel the pain and I say
well what we do as a company
will be running for a number of years
and that's a guaranteed to use it as a
landlord is we take our insurance
policies against all of our tenants so
you know that each and every single
month that you're going to get your rent
paid guaranteed backed up by an
insurance policy that sounds good I had
a conversation with the guy I was
running a program called the um rent to
rent Revolution and I called a landlord
and the landlord said don't do company
lets I said oh that's absolutely fine no
problem I understand have you had a bad
experience
and he said yes I said what happened he
said oh I could write a book
on how bad my experience was with the
company left and he started going on
about what happened yeah well this
happened and it was a party and then
this and then they did this and they
didn't and he was telling me and I said
that sounds really bad it sounds like
they made that that company was awful
they made a lot of Schoolboy errors and
didn't really know what they were doing
I said our company how we work is we
have this in place and we have CCTV and
we have alarms that go off and we have
this and we and we have any guest that
needs to stay in the property we'd check
their ID and as I was explaining how how
we're a little bit different not in a
sales you were just say oh that sounds
terrible did they not have this did they
not have this implant didn't I like you
did they have insurance and then he said
it sounds like you know what you do he
goes look come and have a viewing on the
property and then we'll have a
conversation I came down and viewed the
apartment it turns out he owns the whole
block
he owns the whole and he was like all
right yep take it yeah I've got lots of
problems anytime another property comes
up within the block okay so sometimes
it's about knowing what to say to the
landlord but not just knowing what to
say but also knowing how to back it up
yeah because you can't say oh we know
what we're doing we're trained and
experienced and when you're not because
I'm not going to say everyone's going to
say that everyone will say we can do
this we could do that but you've got to
demonstrate that you can do it yeah and
obviously and the key thing is just like
listening to understand what is how do
you find the landlord's pain points
because let's face it Nick if you phone
up a landlord and they're advertising
their property
all they want to do on that conversation
is say do you want to come and see the
property do you want to book a viewing
do you want to rent it like would you
say find their pain points could you
give me an example of what you mean so
if you're obviously you call them up on
the phone obviously trying obviously if
you're going to get the viewing straight
away and have a face-to-face
conversation which I think is always a
lot easier than trying to kind of do
over the phones that's one of my kind of
techniques is trying to kind of get the
viewing meet them face to face and
obviously that way you can kind of
relate to the people a lot more yeah
because remember communicating 70 is
non-verbal yeah so the more you kind of
if you're with them face to face and
also what I like to do is tell stories
the best way to sell is not actually
selling selling but through telling
stories yeah I've had a landlord very
similar to you in this situation he was
renting with a estate agent he was
unhappy with the service just like
yourself or he had this particular bad
story just like yourself and that way
you're providing your case studies into
the into that storytelling the thing is
landlords generally want two things they
want their rent to be paid on time and
they want the property to take it in
good condition yeah that's it so if you
can do that but then you can find a way
to add value yeah and run it on short
stay let's and you have the
infrastructure to do that yeah make
eight nine in Japan a month per property
and you've got eight of those and then
three more in the pipeline it's
incredible and especially for example
using creative strategies like service
accommodation and say well you get an
instant amount of money with your
current let as a single let is let's
look at what you could potentially make
as a nightly's day and that's why it
kind of goes back to the point where
getting them involved in a share
agreement for example you can take a
profit share is a way for them to say
well I can earn a little bit more the
risk is smaller for you because you're
saying look
all all running a service accommodation
and whatever profit we can split it yeah
um but if it doesn't make profit you're
not losing yeah so you're taking the
management so you're you're agreeing
your management fee it's going to be
slightly reduced management fee than
what you was doing if you're doing a
guaranteed rent but you're saying well
I'm not guaranteeing the rent for
example if it doesn't be successful but
my main job is for it to be successful
and run it based on the evidence that
we've provided in terms of looking at
the data analyzing what is average
occupancy rates in terms of what the
nightly stays are to make sure that
we're going to go into and make it a
winning success what do you prefer do
you prefer steel selling or being an
estate agent the difference is very
obvious people sometimes get confused
deal selling is when you find deals that
are usually with agents already no you
find them you negotiate them and then
you pass it on to an investor and you
get paid a fee for your work what you're
doing is very different people you're
being an estate agent yeah so you're
literally listing problems on the market
and you're getting paid not by the
investor but you're getting paid by the
seller what do you prefer I prefer
estate agency who you're interested and
I think in the UK compared to other
places in the world is in the UK you
work on behalf of the seller there's no
one in the UK that's really kind of set
up a business that's worked on behalf of
the buyer and I want to also to maybe be
a Pioneer for some people this in the UK
that if you're going into your journey
for example you want about your first
time buyer or you're looking to upsize
your house or downsize is to help you
handle that transaction negotiate with
the estate agency on fees handle the
process in terms of dealing with the
conveyancing process because let's take
it I know you've spoke about this many
times before buying a house in the UK is
ridiculously long yeah oh yeah I'm
changing that yes it takes like five to
six months just to transact on that is
absolutely crazy and the percentage of
houses that fall down during that chain
from having a sale agreed is what is
great yeah absolutely absolutely
ridiculous which is why when you see a
house on right move and it says it's
sold some of its contract a lot of
people think oh it's sold I'm not bother
no no no there's a good chance
so for me for example I like the
enjoyment for example of seeing someone
they want to move into the house and
going through that transaction that's
what you get as a personal estate agent
you have someone that's going to be in
your corner fighting you from start all
the way through to completion and
obviously you get to get the big fees at
the end of it which is fantastic but
yeah I do like that but for me also deal
selling for now obviously you've kind of
been on the eviction obviously that that
they were selling a challenge how much
money did you guys make in two days so
in two days our team made I think was 18
18 18 Grand I think it was 40 or 42
overall overall amongst there's only
about eight people yep in in 24 hours
yeah absolutely and that's one of the
things from the eviction that I've taken
forward is that if you give yourself a
year to do something you're going to
take a year if you give yourself a week
or day to do something you'll give
yourself that time to do yeah when you
first joined the Academy I know you Nan
passed yeah like literally two weeks
after yeah and you kind of went a little
bit
um AWOL yeah and went off the radar a
little bit for a while and I think it's
really important that people know that
everyone's on their own Journey it would
have been really easy for you to see
everybody else winning yeah and two
months three months oh my gosh these
people are all making really good money
but everyone has their own journey in
their own path could you talk to me a
little bit about some of the struggles
and problems that you've had within your
business so when I joined the academy
back in in December two weeks after um
my grandson sadly passed away and
obviously for me it took a bit of a kind
of a knock back in terms of kind of my
mindset in terms of where I was at and
many things that happen along in your
journey but the key thing is you've got
to do is make sure that you have a very
strong why and for me that's my family
and my partner my kids tell me kind of
want to kind of leave it leave a legacy
something that you're doing very very
well and that's the challenges that I've
had obviously when I when I went into
property kind of full time is not having
that kind of safety net and so with
people having having a job making sure
bills have got to get paid doing
multiple things in property having to
manage my time so these are kind of the
challenges roadblocks that you kind of
get to get to get to face over that
period of Time how do your family feel
about what you've done because normally
generally speaking at the beginning your
family and friends a lot of them are
like oh my gosh what are you doing but
then when the money starts rolling in
it's like okay and they see the results
what were your friends and family like
when you first got started and how are
they now I mean my close friends are
they've always known that I've been kind
of like almost like a hustler next to
them whatever you do is I've changed my
career multiple times whatever I'm doing
I'm always going to kind of work hard
and kind of do me the best but at the
same time is obviously Partners there
say well you should get a job
yeah I should go back into get a job you
need to do but whatever you're going to
do I'm gonna support it but sometimes
you need to curse you know let's kind of
look at the reality of a situation much
you know this is my passion this is what
I want to do and I'm going to keep going
and keep going and keep going until I'm
going to be successful yeah what did
your partner say when you enrolled onto
the deal finding Extravaganza so she
went to said no why are you spend all
the money on on the training uh you can
kind of do it you don't even do it to
kind of do it yourself but I said look
you need to surround yourself with
like-minded to people yeah you need to
make sure that you're in the in that
environment continuously feed in your
mind getting a knowledge and kind of
getting education they might go well it
costs this amount of money but I'm going
to make x amount of money back going
back and obviously you've done well
exactly you used to be a driving
instructor yeah
um imagine if someone said they didn't
want to pay for a driving instructor
because they think they could figure out
themselves on YouTube exactly what would
you think crazy I think it's all about
mindset as well we think we go to school
we might go to a college we might go to
university but education stops there and
that's a terrible mindset you always
have to be continually developing what
is when sometimes you have to pay for it
you have to invest in yourself
especially when you're speaking to an
investor for example you're trying to
get investment from them but if you're
not prepared to invest in yourself then
it's crazy really good point yeah how
can you expect people to invest in you
when you don't even invest in you yeah
absolutely amazing
um talk to me about the eviction and
what happened and firstly how did you
feel that you came across when you
watched it back yeah it was good weird
just kind of watching yourself back on
TV obviously I as I said on the eviction
I wouldn't have gone in to that process
if I didn't feel I had the skills and
capabilities to to go and to win it I
could give you a whole bunch of stories
of why what happened in the excuses but
that's not me I know for example where I
could have done differently especially
on on the tasks that we kind of lost so
the first task was great obviously we
had to kind of stage the barn kind of
get it done in a short period of time
lots of creative stuff that we did for
example even like getting a lease option
on a table which is was great and then
obviously kind of the deal setting part
of it as well when we got a mass amount
of deals sold and agreed in such a short
pace of time I've come across well
um on there I think one of the comments
you made today I know Nick's hustle
grinds and I think that's what I want to
kind of show as well yeah and for me
obviously it went down to me and Adam in
in the last kind of two on that
particular round and I lost out to the
eventual winner yeah at least
um but no I think I came across well
obviously the thing that on that
challenge I didn't get to sell but I
know for example had that kind kind of
deal that I had kind of gone through
obviously would might have been a
different story yeah and ultimately I
agree I think he came across really well
and everybody on the eviction is doing
extremely well you know I mean I'm
interviewing everyone back to back now
on winners on a Wednesday Isabella Ricky
yourself Adam so it's incredible to see
how well everyone's doing and I've made
mine good friends good connections I
think when you're in that kind of
environment it's almost like it's so
intense anything only there for like two
or three weeks but you're with them
every single day and you're all kind of
striving for this all hungry it's a
amazing bunch of people and everyone is
doing amazing so you've got a couple of
bites left how are you bites doing in
this market yeah so the back tests are
pretty good one of them we just went
through a remortgage
um we want we're hoping to pull out 50
Grand in terms of equity but obviously
with the marking and the lending
situation basically they change their
calculations we have to kind of just
stay with our mortgage provider and just
did a switch product off of the rate so
he wasn't able to pull out that cash are
you putting out any cash when they
change the situation lending we want
able to pull out the money but we're
looking at a creative way where we can
kind of take maybe a second charge on
the on the property where are you buy
for that so one buy to let is in Slough
it's where I used to live yeah and the
other bike to letters in South London
nice and those properties are they cash
flow and positive yeah what do you
prefer owning Properties or controlling
properties
um I think controlling is is very very
good because obviously you you can scale
a little quicker let's say for example
if you have in the mindset I need to own
own it's going to take a long time to
kind of get the deposit and save up for
the deposit and all the fees that come
associated with that you've got the
deposit legals and what stuff where you
can say let's say 50 grand for example
to buy a house for 200 Grand you can
take the 50 Grand and get five rent to
rent yeah and and cash flow great and
then once you have the cash flow because
cash is King as they say then you put it
into ownership so the ownership is good
for your wealth wealth building
long-term growth long term But
ultimately to get out your job yeah
because as you mentioned earlier it
takes five six months just to buy a
house yeah whereas get around to rent
five six days and then I buy selecting a
rent to rent they're probably going to
give you a similar amount of cash flow
in fact I don't know many people that
are making more than eight nine hundred
pound a month cash flow from buy to that
so if anything's going to give you more
monthly income no it's quicker quicker
so if you want to get out your job rent
when it's quick much better but then you
should build up your long-term well
it'll be long-term wealth but that money
into the assets where you're owning you
do bras where you have an important of
cash and you're recycling that same pot
of cash and that's what's going to build
up your long-term wealth what's your
best advice for people watching this
that maybe want to get into property
they want to like yourself do lots of
different aspects do property whether it
be deal selling rent to rent buy to let
ownership what would you say to people
that want to really get started if
anyone's looking at this and wanting to
kind of get started and think about well
I'm in a job that I don't like it's
first kind of just sit down with a black
piece of paper
and understand where this you are now
and where it is you want to kind of get
to and then almost you can kind of
working back from from that goal and
it's like well this is where I want to
kind of get to and how can I get there
but the key thing is not having that
kind of limited belief imagine what you
could do if you couldn't fail so go and
go into that mindset and make sure
whatever it is you're going to do is
that you put yourself in the right
environment to get the right knowledge
but then and then when you get the right
knowledge they say knowledge is power
but it's potential power without taking
the right action yeah so I I call it kba
knowledge belief action yeah love that
and what's the plan then for this year
so for this year instead of going back
to my free pillars uh The Core Business
which is obviously rent to rent and
Property Management we're going to be
scaling we're going to be growing
growing that so taking on more rentals
taking on more managements and it's kind
of build up that kind of cash flow
selling real estate and so I've launched
my own real estate company which is
Nicholas Eiffel real estate uh so the
key there is to kind of grow that work
with uh homeowners are kind of get into
the maximum price for for that at the
home specializing in the luxury real
estate and then deal selling as well so
for me it's kind of those three pillars
building a team building a business
because I also want to kind of get to
the point where I'm not in the business
because otherwise I didn't have a job so
I wanted to kind of get to the point
where I can build it and then I can step
out of it as well yeah incredible what
do your what does your partner think
about what you're doing now and actually
seeing the results and everything she's
seen the eviction they're my partner
Believes In Me which which I I'm very
very grateful for it's hard as well
obviously she's there to see what we've
got a young family we've got to provide
but I know that I have a support and I'm
very ever indebted to her for that yeah
so I want to say thank you to her for
supporting me through this journey
amazing bro well massive respect for
what you've done what you've achieved
thanks for coming out I appreciateful to
watch you continue to win bro
foreign
[Music]